hey this is presh tillwalker
semicircle d e has a right triangle d e
f placed over it where f is exterior to
the semicircle
let the region contained in the
semicircle not contained in the triangle
have an area equal to a
and let the region exterior to the
semicircle contained in the triangle
have an area equal to b
if a is equal to b plus 47 and d e is
equal to 20
what is the length of ef
i think min for the suggestion
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching to
learn how to solve this problem
[Music]
there's a very neat trick to solve this
problem
consider the third region where the
semi-circle and the right triangle
overlap and suppose it has area c
to the equation a is equal to b plus 47
add the area c to both sides
we now have a plus c is equal to b plus
c plus 47
but what is a plus c
it's exactly the area of the semicircle
the area of the semicircle is equal to
pi r squared over two
in this case r is equal to d e over two
this will be equal to ten
so the area of the semicircle is ten
squared pi all over 2 which is equal to
50 pi
we then subtract 47 from both sides to
get b plus c is equal to 50 pi minus 47
but what is b plus c equal to
this is exactly the area of the right
triangle d e f
and the area of the right triangle is
equal to d e multiplied by e f all over
2.
substituting d e is equal to 20 and then
dividing by 2 gives 10 e f
is equal to 50 pi minus 47
dividing both sides of the equation by
10 gives e f is equal to 5 pi minus 4.7
which is approximately equal to 11.01
and that's the answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve the world's problems one video at
a time
[Music]
you